hey what's up you guys Denny direct oh
whether you're a Democrat or a
Republican whether your candidate won or
lost I think we can all agree that it
has been a crazy and stressful election
and if you're like me I'm ready to kind
of get a little piece of my life back
you know so here to help us get through
that is Richard Barker professional
hypnotist so we're gonna find out how
hypnosis can help us kind of deal with
the stress that this election has caused
right people say you know there was a
volatile election or it was traumatic
election actually it was an emotional
election a lot of the frustration and
kind of hostility people are expecting
to end once those ballots were cast but
as we're seen it's really hit a fever
pitch so talk to me a little bit more
about self hypnosis how does it work
it's an internal dialogue that you would
have with yourself once taught and you
would typically learn from a hypnotist
it would be things like I teach my
clients visualization so if everything's
going wrong and life is horrible like
some people think it is at the moment
zactly how can you close your eyes and
visualize a better seen than it actually
is
we have four gracious volunteers from
the et staff to join me and get
hypnotized I think it's awesome
we're cozy and we're all yours we are
ready to get over the election back into
celebrity news right guys some of the
misconceptions with hypnosis are I can
hypnotize you against your will and
extract your deepest darkest secrets
from you it can't get stuck in hypnosis
and I think's gonna happen to you that
you don't want to happen you're
expecting some lotion potion or magic
pixie dust and there isn't any I'm not
Harry Potter so whatever happened today
don't worry about it don't worry about
the election don't worry about yesterday
or the day before I'm actually gonna by
the time you leave the room you will
feel better about yourself relax if I
ask you to drift float and melt on a
soft fluffy cloud of relaxation don't
worry about the cloud and how it looks
and don't worry about the density of the
cloud don't be analytical
now just for a few seconds I want you to
do me a favor I want you open your eyes
I know just want is stare at an object
in front of you not another human being
if ever I ask you to open your eyes and
look for an object you'll find the
object you're looking at right now and
as you stare at that object I want you
to just think of sleep allow all the
worries troubles aches and pains to
simply melt away this time when you
breathe in your eyes will close and when
you breathe out you'll allow your heavy
head to rest down to your chest breathe
in close your eyes and breathe out
imagine a wave of relaxation from the
top of your head down through the tips
of your toes almost as if nothing
matters from this point forward other
than the sound of my voice
trying to open your eyes but you can't
keep them stuck trying to clear eyes but
you can't keep them locked down stuck
try and open your eyes but you can't
imagine them stuck now in a few moments
but not yet I'll come up and down the
line I'll be touching you on the left or
right wrist just allow yourself to relax
like a ragdoll that's good my friend
loose and limp sinking drifting relaxing
let it go then any aches and pains
worries and stresses that's good my
friend just simply relax relax in your
arms your legs are facing your life
controls you and you control life from
what's in your destiny is what you
control if you do in fact ever hear me
say the word sleep from this point
forward your eyes will immediately close
you'll sink down in your chair just like
ragdolls
from this point forward each day in
every way you'll in fact feel better
about yourself in fact every time you
breathe and every time you blink and
relax and collapse you'll feel all the
stress and anxiety worries and troubles
will simply disappear from you you want
to and three eyes open wide awake
welcome back everybody I was just
explaining the power of the mind and how
sometimes you can deflect sort of
negative thought processes what I didn't
get your first name brother what was
again Danny Richard and I say sleep just
relaxing my friend and the deeper you go
the better you feel Danny give me a
longest hand look at this one real fast
just give me that longest hand over
there longer Sam look at this finger
look at the longer side see the ring
right there yeah they'll give me a
longest time right there because I sleep
just from that's my friend
you're looking around on this is weird
aren't ya III think that every time I do
it actually is crazy
to sleep close your eyes my friend just
relax will there be filtered picture
taking a deep breath in look over this
way look over that one look over the
butterfly go look at the ring on there
see that I'm there but look at the
butterfly and look at Alex right there
look there see them over there give me a
hand
push down just relax me let it go just
relax
okay cool I got you that's fine just
relax okay one two and three eyes open
welcome back everybody taking a deep
breath in push all the aches and pains
out and just close your eyes just relax
count from 1 up to 5 you feel better
than you've ever felt before
one familiar face ring alert from the
live to four like your Bader eyes in a
cool mountain spring 3 feeling the
energy rushing into your veins for for
them better than you've ever felt before
and in a second but not yet on five eyes
open fully alert and wide awake five
eyes open feeling refreshed to give
yourself a round of applause alright you
guys
perfect levels of hypnosis they're right
there
no relaxed yeah I've got well you know
what I asked you to raise your arm I
felt it right there immediately
yes so you're some non-ballistic that
that's the term foot for you mild medium
I will say the one thing I noticed is
when you were talking about the election
which I've been very stressed out over
there I couldn't think of what I was
pissed about right which was kind of odd
mild but there you felt relaxed bit of
resistance and I was on the fence with
you I must admit cuz you were they were
tension in your arm but then I saw the
eye balls it's called Spiegel I roll
where I saw the whites of your eye just
like you said just give up and just
listen to your words and I mean that
overall just made me forget everything
just listen to you I felt really anxious
going to like where we recited close our
eyes I felt really anxious like fill my
palms were really clammy oh yeah and I
just was freaking stir like
I don't know if I surrender but I was
lost oh yeah me too
right now if you were to say sleep would
he go back not now cuz I counted from
one up to five you had your work cut out
for you because I mean like yeah it's
not easy environment no it's not at all
you know what people are watching here I
mean so it's like crazy
take on the world thanks for watching ET
on youtube but wait wait wait before you
go there's plenty more where that came
from all you got to do is hit the
subscribe button